il avait une position assez spécifique
sur la question de l'autonomie
c'était un autonomiste
il était beaucoup plus si l'autonomie
politique que l'autonomie de gestion est
d'ailleurs ce qui l'a conduit à un
moment donné à ce s'écarter du parti par
sa première des missions à mener
sacrement et ensuite sa démission
définitive 1,90 par une approche qu'il a
lui-même je veux rester extrêmement
honnête vis-à-vis de lui la question du
nom en droit il a considéré que le
moratoire sortait la martinique
dynamique de combat de la responsabilité
et que ça mettait fin à ce vrai combat
pour l'autonomie
je partage pas tout à fait surprenant
parce que tu aimé césaire avait une
double opposition la première position
c'est considérer que moratoire n'arrête
pas la dynamique
c'est un instant de pause il expliqué
initié à la pause parce qu'il disait
clairement que au moment où ni terrain
arrivé au pouvoir il milite bien sûr où
mitterrand pour le socialisme et la
cause sociale sunnites et assainissement
même temps nos résultats en dents tmx x
giscard d'estaing à table à quoi donc il
a considéré qu' on n'était pas prêt pour
aller plus rapidement en autonomie et
qu'il fallait faire cette pause qu'il
appelait le monde doit arthur j ça qu'on
se pose la con c était un art est bon de
la dynamique
ensuite une deux positions mais en
turris et rester je pense jusqu'à ce
qu'un jour quelqu'un de très fidèle à
terre et surtout un scénariste de
première heure
c'est pas parce qu'il avait désaccord
sur la question du moratoire qu'il était
de venir quelqu'un qui est opposé à ces
artistes
flo rida fidèles comme il a toujours été
un fidèle à la cause du vin gauche des
progrès si d'une manière générale avec
sa particularité est son caractère